moving quickly to execute the plans we
had put in place to respond to every
constituency including and contingency
he says he made contingency plans for
this bull no he did not i will always
say somebody is stupid rather than
perverse but this is stupidity bordering
on the perverse joe biden
yesterday he gave a speech
and his speech was supposed to lay out
the rationale for this remember he was
off in camp david he had called a lid
joe biden had no plans to actually speak
to the american public until like
wednesday or thursday because after all
joe biden was eating ice cream and
watching math lock up in camp david he
couldn't be bothered all he did over the
weekend was release a photo of himself a
pathetic looking photo of himself alone
in the situation room talking via
conference call with all the generals
who had already advised him not to do
this
and then monitoring the collapse of
afghanistan in real time well finally he
flew back to washington dc
he did a a little speech at the white
house and then he took like three
questions and then he left and that was
it
because here's the thing about your
caring grandfatherly empathetic old man
president he does not give one damn
about the people we made promises to he
doesn't care that americans are still
stuck in in afghanistan right now
somewhere between five and ten thousand
of them he does not care that tens of
thousands when i say tens of thousands i
mean probably at least a hundred
thousand people who are connected to the
afghan government who are allies people
who worked on intelligence with us
people who served in the afghan military
with the united states military and
their families those people are stuck
there and they will remain stuck there
and joe biden does not give a bleep for
captain humanitarian policy over here it
turns out he doesn't care it doesn't
matter one iota to him because in the
end he's just a venal corrupt old
politician that's all he is that's all
he ever was he was never
captain empathy now i've said a thousand
times that you should not look to
politicians for empathy
right if you're looking to politicians
for empathy you're looking in the wrong
place because politics shouldn't be
about empathy
politics should be about making
hard-headed decisions but that's the
thing joe biden's decision here wasn't
even hard-headed real politic
it was not a realist foreign policy
decision his decision here was very
simple he was going to abandon
afghanistan come hell or high water and
hell on high water have come
okay so he made the speech yesterday and
it was notable for its complete lack of
honesty the number of lies that joe
biden told in the speech it beggars the
imagination
the number of for varications
the self-congrat i've never seen a
president congratulate himself on a
greater failure than this
this is as though gerald ford had called
the presser
after the abandonment of saigon and then
congratulated himself for his bravery in
abandoning millions of people to the
evils of the viet cong remember
afghanistan by the way is 38 million
people live in afghanistan
but that's exactly what joe biden did
joe biden had a press conference where
he blamed every single person other than
himself
everyone as we'll see he blamed everyone
for the decision that he alone made in
precipitous fashion
against the advice of his generals
against the advice of his intelligence
authorities against the advice of all
prior presidents he made this call he
owns this call but he tried to blame
everybody else and he patted himself on
the back as a man of high moral
character for having abandoned people
the united states made commitments to
we're running out of allies to betray
here
we've betrayed the kurds
we've betrayed the people of hong kong
we've done nothing for the dissidents in
iran we've done nothing for the
descendants in cuba and now we've
allowed people who we actively engaged
with people we actively encourage to
fight back against the taliban and by
the way they did fifty thousand five
zero thousand fifty thousand afghan
military members have been killed in the
last seven years alone fighting against
the talibans when you hear all these
people saying the afghan military wasn't
willing to fight we were we were
fighting their war for them the united
states has not been in an active combat
role in afghanistan since 2014 when nato
officially stopped doing that
last year since february 20 since
february 8th 2020 the united states has
not lost a soldier in combat
not one
and we were losing
either low double digits or single
digits numbers of soldiers in combat in
afghanistan year on year since 2014.
meanwhile the afghan military was taking
tens of thousands of casualties so the
notion that the afghan military has been
doing nothing over the past few years is
just a lie
we'll discuss that in just a second
because again joe biden blamed the
afghan military for decisions he himself
made
but we begin at the beginning with joe
biden's pathetic muelling disgusting
speech i mean this is really one of the
most disreputable speeches i've ever
seen an american president give it is
despicable it is morally despicable it
is a despicable lie through and through
so let's start at the beginning first he
starts with an open lie he says he made
contingency plans for this bull no he
did not he did not even come close to
making contingency contingency plans for
this here is joe biden just lying right
right out the gate here
my national security team and i have
been closely monitoring the situation on
the ground in afghanistan
and moving quickly to execute the plans
we had put in place
to respond to every constituency
including and contingency
including the rapid collapse
we're seeing now
okay you had no plans for the rapid
collapse we're seeing now in fact joe
biden would later admit that by the way
what were those plans exactly i mean
let's go through what's exactly been
happening in afghanistan over the last
several days remember this
administration said that the taliban
would not take over the country period
as of july
anthony blinken said like a few weeks
ago
there would be no situation which the
taliban over the course of a weekend
took over afghanistan which is basically
what they did it took about a week like
a week and a half
from them taking over like the the third
biggest city in afghanistan so then
taking over kandahar and then taking
over kabul hey i mean let's just go
through this we saw over the weekend
helicopters taking off from the roof of
the us embassy evacuating u.s embassy
personnel
did he have a contingency plan for that
we saw afghans rushing the airport now
remember this is because the united
states decided to abandon baogram air
base to the predations of the taliban so
he had no military air base from which
to fly people out
only the kabul airport was available and
the united states did not have enough
people there to defend the kabul airport
so people were just rushing the tarmac
you can see the afghans climbing the
walls attempting to get in
okay you can i mean this video afghans i
mean this is stunning footage afghans
running along with the us air force
plane
clinging to the wings of the plane
clinging to the wit was that the
contingency plan mr president
those are those are human beings sitting
on the okay this one is the most
egregious of all obviously you can see
you see that dot falling right there
those two dots falling right there those
are people those are human beings
okay this entire debacle began with
human beings jumping from the twin
towers on 9 11 after al qaeda based in
afghanistan harbored by the taliban hit
the twin towers and now this debacle
ends with afghans falling from the
wheels of american planes those afghans
climbed into the wheels of the american
planes to try and escape the theater the
theocratic tyranny of the taliban
by the way another story from politico
today body of dead afghan found in
landing gear of military jet leaving
kabul airport
the body of an afghan so desperate to
escape the country hours after kabul
fell to the taliban was found in the
landing gear of a c-17 transport
aircraft hours after it hastily took off
from muhammad karzai international
airport according to two sources
familiar with the matter
the body in the aircraft's landing gear
has made it temporarily inoperable the
sources said
by the way some seven people were killed
at the on the tarmac because of the rush
on the tarmac
apparently the taliban are now going
house to house and killing people
and that's the fallout bill crystal
tweeted this out he's been receiving
texts from people in afghanistan by the
way i'm getting emails from people
desperately trying to get the afghan
interpreters they worked with members of
the military who are now in the united
states trying to get members of the
afghan military who they worked with
their translators people they worked
with in the military out of afghanistan
and receiving no support from the biden
administration in doing this i'm getting
emails about it
bill crystal tweeted out i just got off
the phone with somebody who recently
returned from his third tour in
afghanistan he emphasized we had a
responsibility not just to translators
but to afghan troops pilots and special
forces in particular who'd fought
bravely by our side
and he continued by pointing out that he
had received a text quote terrorists are
going door to door and killing pilots
and special operating forces raping
their families taking their houses two
of my friends were shot dead in kabul
meanwhile just just in case you didn't
know what the taliban are up to uh
they've also been painting out the
images of women if there are any images
of women in kabul they're going around
with white paints and they're painting
over them to make sure that women are
never seen again
okay that that was the contingency plan
from joe biden okay he said that right
out of the gate in this speech that was
his opening gambit was we had a
contingency plan
it's a hell of a contingency plan right
there that was just the beginning of the
lies
joe biden continues and he talks about
he he makes the case that the united
states actually accomplished its goal
in afghanistan
okay well
not really
i mean here's the thing in order for us
to accomplish our goal in afghanistan
our goal in afghanistan was pretty clear
right our goal in afghanistan was that
we were supposed to counter terrorism in
order to do that we have to continue to
counter terrorism when you stop
countering terrorism you've no longer
achieved your goal here is joe biden
we went to afghanistan almost 20 years
ago
with clear goals
get those who attacked us on september
11 2001
and
make sure al qaeda could not use
afghanistan as a base from which to
attack us again
we did that
we severely degraded al-qaeda in
afghanistan
we never gave up the hunt for osama bin
laden and we got him
that was a decade ago
okay now here's the problem
how about the fact that you just
reconstituted the possibility of al
qaeda in afghanistan according to the
chairman of the joint chiefs of staff
general mark milley he informed congress
terror groups are likely to reconstitute
in afghanistan within the next two years
high probability according to dr sajan
goho of the asia pacific foundation
quoted by the bbc there are some 250 to
500 members of al-qaeda in kunar which
is a heavily forested valley region of
afghanistan right now we were able to
monitor that place and we were able to
fight with them no longer go home now
says the number is likely to increase
given the united states lack of access
to any intelligence network and its
surrender of all air bases in
afghanistan
also pakistan has now cut a quid pro quo
with the taliban to now reject u.s bases
on pakistani territory so we can't even
use pakistani territory to launch
attacks against the taliban or against
al qaeda
which means we are back to shooting
camels in the ass with cruise missiles
bill clinton's style from 1998
so it's pretty likely that terrorist
groups are about to reconstitute quickly
in afghanistan and i know that we live
in the post-9 11 era
i know that that 911 was sort of a blip
in a lot of people's imaginations it was
20 years ago after all but let's just
remember that things that happen in
far-off countries can have some rather
radical impact in the united states just
a reminder this is why we went into
afghanistan the first place this right
here
i know we don't play this footage very
often anymore i know we're not supposed
to because it's upsetting and
disquieting
and and shocking still 20 years later
that's the reason we went to afghanistan
because 3 000 americans were murdered on
september 11th by people the taliban
were harbouring
hey that's why we were there in the damn
first place and those same people are
just ushered back into power by joe
biden
ushered back into power with no capacity
the united states just destroyed its own
capacity to wage war on these people
that's what the united states just did
by the way the taliban you know there's
this myth out there being propo being
portrayed
and and perverted by the by the body
administration that the taliban is
moderated really interesting because
like two years ago the taliban chief
spokesperson was saying you know al
qaeda wasn't even behind 911. this is on
cbs this morning from just a couple of
years ago
more stunning was shaheen's refusal to
accept al qaeda's responsibility for the
september 11th attacks
so who's the real culprit behind so sure
that was not known who
still it is not known who was behind
they claimed
if there responsibility
a
proof
given to us we are ready
to try him
so
that was just two years ago the taliban
saying it was not all kind of by the way
that was the original line as well you
will recall so now they're back in power
they're not just back in power they they
now have control of billions of dollars
of us military equipment including mine
resistant ambush protected vehicles
drones humvees they have a lot of
american intel we didn't burn our stuff
before we left they have all that stuff
because joe biden decided to pull out
with no plan with no forethought because
he is a
he is a dead set idiot
i mean
either that or he's or he's perverse i
mean those are really the only two
choices and and using hanlon's razor
here i will always say somebody is
stupid rather than perverse but this is
stupidity bordering on the perverse
how's this for a title ben shapiro show
subscriber destroys like button with
clicks and logic i'd watch that make it
happen gang